hot breath how meticulous is the prep
for those sets
for conan yeah i have a good enough
relationship now that he's kind of like
he lets me play with it a little the
first one was a little more meticulous
but like word for word
yeah but now i'm like can i say and
he's like i'd rather you then
see if you can do it without saying
uh-huh here i think it's better
and it's defensive it's usually on the
money like because they can't
it's not like a cable it's like
it's like a regular where i think
they just
don't let you hear the word at all okay
even though it is on cable but it's late
i don't know the rules whatever but
uh so it's better not cursing those sets
but uh
sometimes i don't know if they're
helping like i just
i have no idea what's helping and what's
not helping i think some weekends people
come out for them
and then other weekends they don't so i
don't know how specific is your
performance piece
because it seems like even just to go
back to the predator joke
and how you end it talking about the
predators and the the nashville
predators and their name the hockey team
and then at the very end of the joke you
say
i don't remember the last line but you
do like this hand gesture with it
is it does it come down to that specific
no no no definitely not the hand gesture
definitely not i think i'm just thinking
are you sure you haven't moved your hand
in a while okay i think that's what it
is
but i look at comedy under the
microscope of like oh he raised his
eyebrow there
oh he moved his hand here that's not all
super choreography that's not
me but that's if i were a better comic
that would probably be me that's
something that you probably should think
about but uh
no i'm just thinking like don't flub a
word don't uh
just nail the delivery name i for me
comedy is very uh
it's visual but it's also like the sound
of comedy so important to me like i
always thought like
like i listened to so many albums
growing up of comedy so like the way you
deliver a punchline was always important
to me that the way you
kind of as you say a lot of the jokes
end on applause well
that's a lot about how you i think carry
your voice too
you know that you you know how to just
say the punchline the right way you have
like
a lot of comics they have a way they say
a punchline
you know that's like they're almost like
they have like their punchline voice and
it's like a queue almost it is yeah it's
very manipulative now that we know we're
talking about it
no but it's uh yeah you almost like
once they know you they know what you're
going for but i mean look
it's got to be funny they're not going
to laugh they're not just going to laugh
at a shitty
voice